i have been a public servant for 35  years  at the bbc uh running news  i then left and we did public service  running the royal opera house which is  that time was in crisis  i rescued the cultural olympics for the  olympics in 2012 and i came back to the  bbc  which i never thought i ever would do or  wanted to in 2013  uh to rescue the bbc from the crisis  that was involving savile  25 years ago myself and everybody  believed bashir we made a mistake but  please don't let that color  the other things that i've done and  which i can enumerate but obviously  won't  in terms of my public record of public  service over 35 years  i've done a hell of a lot for the bbc  and and i think for the arts  and i regret this one thing that we all  got wrong because we were lied to  by martin bashir 25 years ago